all right guys
bang bang before i forget while we're
letting people get in here um go into
the description right now i write a
daily email
uh that goes out to over 50 000
investors it's all about business
technology and finance
if you go there what you can see is
all of my daily thoughts i'm going to
quickly get this posted
on twitter and then we will be off to
the races
go subscribe at pompletter.com again
pompletter.com
and we will uh see you there all right
so as we get started here here's what i
want to cover i want to go through a
whole bunch of stuff
but mostly i want to cover what is the
current
small business environment and what i
mean by that is
we have lived now through a economic
crisis that was driven by a public
health crisis and so i want to just go
over
what's going on for small businesses
across america
if you think about uh go back to january
and february
of this year essentially there was
one of the greatest economic situations
in the united states history
so we had seen everything from
record low unemployment we had seen an
explosion in the stock market we were at
literally one of the longest bull runs
if not the longest bull run
in history everything seemed to be going
really really well
there were signs last year that we were
getting towards the end
of the economic cycle everything from
inverted yield curves
to gyrations in the kind of lending
markets
uh there are in the repo markets there
was
a lot of ceos leaving um their their
posts and so just generally i think
people were saying hey wait a second
we may be getting towards the end of uh
this economic cycle
and so when you think through this it
then says okay that's all in the public
markets but then we had this public
health crisis
uh government mandated shutdowns
occurred uh and the
federal reserve used the 2008-2009 uh
playbook
they said if all of a sudden there is
going to be some economic carnage here
because the velocity of money is slowed
down because everyone's sitting at home
we're going to step in and we are
basically going to use what i personally
call
bridge the gap monetary stimulus and
what i mean by that
is there was no secret that there was
going to be a very big
drop uh when it came to economic output
in the united states and so that drop
was going to
uh be very painful people were going to
lose their jobs there was going to be
businesses going out of business et
cetera and so what
the federal reserve basically did they
said we're going to step in and we're
going to
manipulate the interest rate environment
so they had two emergency rate cuts
dropped us down to zero percent
they said but also on top of that what
we're going to do is we're going to
print a bunch of money
and so what they did was they ended up
printing over three trillion dollars
um and and so through those monetary
stimulus packages
uh what they essentially tried to do is
they tried to inflate
the economic situation to mitigate that
damage
uh and the thought process was this
virus is going to take its toll
we'll probably be shut for two four six
maybe eight weeks
um but if we have the programs extend
out far enough
into uh the end of july uh for the
beefed up unemployment
and into the end of uh september for ppp
loans and things like that then we'll be
able to bridge the gap right kind of
as the the economy and economic activity
drops we'll go ahead and use the
stimulus it'll bridge the gap and by the
time that these programs run out
we then will have the recovery of the
economic data well fast forward
to where we are today we're now the
month of september uh some of the
programs have run out
uh but also we have not seen the
economic recovery that i think people
really
had hoped for and so where we are is we
are in a situation where my estimation
is
twenty percent to zero twenty percent of
small businesses in the united states
are going to go out of business
we are going to lose twenty percent of
small businesses now
if you go and you look at let's say the
impact on jobs for example
50 of jobs in america come from small
businesses
right 50 are due to small businesses
and so if we lost 20 of small businesses
that means that we would lose
about right in generalizing 10 of all
jobs in america
now this past week what we saw was the
unemployment rate dropped below 10
uh for the first time in a long time um
and so
the the estimates may be a little off in
either direction
but that's about the ballpark of what i
think we're going to see here so when
you kind of
then cut the small business environment
and say
where are we seeing um you know
businesses thrive
and where are we seeing businesses
suffer and ultimately what it comes down
to is
if you think through a digital first
perspective
the businesses that were optimized for
the digital world
are doing well the businesses that were
not optimized for the digital world
or not doing well right so that that's
the perspective i think people have to
take
and when you think through it as a small
business owner
uh or small business entrepreneur what
you have to say to yourself
is i'm going to be intellectually honest
with myself
am i prepared for a digital world am i
set up to
thrive in a digital world yes there are
still physical components to many of
these businesses whether it's their
physical goods their retail locations
all of that kind of stuff
but ultimately what you have to ask
yourself is i have to reimagine my
business
through the digital uh first lens right
that digital
native lens and this isn't a new trend
this trend was already underway
it's just that the virus accelerated the
trend
right so businesses already knew hey i
gotta get online okay now i'm online how
do i optimize this
you know all of these things that small
business owners already knew
but what they thought was they might
have had five or ten years to make the
transition
now all of a sudden they got punched in
the face and they've got to do it
immediately
right and so this was just the
acceleration of a trend
so when i see that happening i think
what people need to really think through
is i am a small business owner how do i
optimize for a
digital first world and so i'm going to
go through a diff a couple of different
sectors here and really try to
unpack what i think businesses should be
doing
now let's start with restaurants right
so uh there's a bunch of data points i
have
uh you know in local restaurants and i'm
gonna use new york city as an example
just because that's where i live
uh that's where i've got the most data
for so in new york city
uh the current regulatory environment is
that politicians have decided
uh that they cannot have indoor seating
so you can have
a a restaurant open uh but you cannot do
indoor seating uh maybe as long as until
a vaccine is
found and approved so that could be for
a very very long time if
it ever happens so if you're a
restaurateur
in new york city what can you do one is
many of them have built outdoor seating
so literally they've been given
permission to go out into the street
they've built kind of these little box
type structures
they put some tables out there and they
basically carry out the operations of
their restaurant but now they're doing
it outdoors rather than indoors
so as you can imagine you can't put as
many chairs and seats outside as you
could once do
inside so immediately your capacity is
constrained
the things that i see businesses doing
that i think are very smart
are one they immediately embrace
curbside pickup
so how can you optimize your operations
to not only continue to serve customers
sitting outside in chairs
but also to optimize for curbside
pickups so somebody can order a head
right if you think through
dominoes and starbucks why have dominoes
in starbucks businesses
exploded stock prices taken off over the
last five years
was because they got very very good at
mobile ordering
right and that mobile ordering or online
ordering business
for dominoes is world-class for
starbucks if you ever walk into a
starbucks now and you watch people are
ordering on
on the mobile app and they're just
coming and picking it up every
restaurant is going to have to embrace
that kind of
online ordering or mobile ordering first
so this is order online i come pick it
up you have to have an
optimized experience for that what i
mean by that
is if somebody orders from you online
and they come to pick it up and all of a
sudden they're sitting there waiting for
20 minutes
that's not a good experience they're
unlikely to do it again unless your food
is
really really really good right it's one
of their favorites
and so what you have to start to think
of is how do i optimize the customer
experience
for this new way of purchasing uh food
from me right so that's first of all
second of all what you see then is an
integration with all the food delivery
companies so there are still restaurants
literally in new york city who are not
integrated into seamless and grubhub and
ubereats and all of these different
uh services so getting optimized there
ends up being really important again you
need
volume in order to keep up in a low
margin environment right most
restaurants are sub
20 margin businesses and so that's where
i think you see kind of the easy steps
right one i got optimized for online
ordering and curbside pickup
and then two is i gotta uh integrate
with and optimize for
uh online ordering and food delivery
services so that's
two the third thing is every single
restaurant
should immediately start thinking about
intellectual property right what is the
iep that you have
that you can productize and immediately
create a new revenue stream so
for those who listen to the podcast i
had cat cole come on
cat cole started out working at hooters
moved all the way up to vice president
she eventually took over as the
president of cinnabun and then now is
the president and ceo
of focus brands which owns cinnabun
jamba juice most southwest grill
a bunch of other services uh you know
our companies uh auntie annes etc
one of their their uh core strategies is
how do we take the
intellectual property that we have at
the restaurants uh and these chains
and create additional additive products
that we then can go
and sell through other channels so for
example if you are a restaurant and
you're known for having great cookies
can you now productize that cookie
product or that cookie
productize it so that you can then sell
it online right and then you can do some
sort of e-commerce integration
again this is moving restaurant tours
outside of
their uh kind of comfort zone but it's
really important for them to be able to
do this
because this is where the customers are
you have to now start going to where the
customers are the customers are online
the customers are looking for new types
of ways to
interact with your business and so iep
is a huge piece of this right whether
that is
taking the iep and putting it onto
merchandise putting
uh some sort of uh food together
creating new products right
uh a restaurant i ate at last night uh a
friend of mine runs
uh and not only does he have his own
wine but he also has his own olive oil
and other things right so he's been able
to take the products that they use
inside of the restaurant
and they're now creating ip products
with ip
that they then can turn and they can
sell uh online and things like that and
so
i think that's a key piece for
restaurants uh today
to actually start to make sure that not
only one can they survive this but they
can begin to thrive in a digital first
world
the second thing that i think
restaurants have to start to understand
is that they have to reimagine their
space
so when you begin to look at a
restaurant from a physical location
standpoint the square footage that you
have about 80 percent of the square
footage usually is for dine-in
customers well if now all of a sudden
the government won't let you actually
put customers as a dining experience you
immediately can expand your operations
right
can you go from making x amount of food
to x times three
by simply expanding into that dining
space and then
can you actually turn it into a ghost
kitchen can you do certain things where
you can
drastically uh increase your output and
what you rely on
is now you leveraging either online
ordering or the delivery services
to increase the demand for you right so
you become more of a warehouse
uh or like a ghost kitchen more so than
a dine-in restaurant
now if people understand what like jeff
bezos and whole foods are doing
in brooklyn i believe it is they just
announced for the first time that
they are going to set up a whole foods
location that has no walk-in customers
and what that ends up being is
it's essentially just a warehouse right
but you're going to be able to order
whole foods
uh the groceries off the internet and
that physical location people will not
walk in
what they will use is they'll use it to
kind of pick and pack your orders
and then they will deliver it um to
wherever your location is and so
what they've essentially done is they've
created the first hub
that uh is going to serve as the point
for the delivery in a certain radius
right but they're using the physical
location so imagine in a grocery store
all of a sudden now i don't need to have
a bunch of
really wide aisles with great lights and
kind of worry about how the produce is
laid out and make sure that there's
great displays and
have all of the space taken up by the
cash registers right you begin to
reimagine
what is this you know box space or this
warehouse type space
how can i actually utilize the space for
the most efficiency to get the most
groceries in
so that we can deliver them fast as
possible right so you change the way
and you become much more efficient with
the use of the space i think restaurants
are gonna have to start thinking of the
same thing right
how can you use the space that you have
to actually begin to
optimize yourself for this digitally
first world now
on top of all of that one of the things
that i uh saw early on in the pandemic
that i thought was really interesting
was people were selling these uh
bonds right they basically were saying
hey if you come in right now and you buy
five meals we're going to basically give
you a gift card to some degree right
and for those five millions you actually
get seven later or six later
right that is a type of uh kind of
digitally native first thought process
right where they're trying to use
uh virality or something else in order
to um
actually get people to come in and
purchase things and so i think that
restaurants have to start thinking about
well what are the internet companies or
the digitally native companies do
that i could do here so for example is
there a world where
you can actually create a a kind of a
social invite or a friend invite program
so
uh imagine if somebody comes into your
restaurant and you say hey
if you come back in the next two weeks
with three or more people
you'll get your meal for free right and
now all of a sudden what you're doing is
you're
using them after having a great
experience to go recruit three or four
friends to come
they get their meal for free right or
hey if you go get your friends and you
bring three or more friends next time in
the next
two weeks what i'll do is i'll give you
to all 25 off your meal
right so you start to actually unpack
how can you generate the virality at a
restaurant a physical location
um and to actually bring more and more
people in you can also do the same thing
online right
hey if you order and use this code and
then you go and invite your friends you
can go ahead and do this again this is
pushing restaurant tours
outside of their comfort zone but this
is what it's going to take for
restaurants to thrive
in the current environment right we've
now moved from an analog first world
for most small businesses to a digitally
native first world
for those businesses and so you see the
large tech companies you see the large
retail chains doing this we now need to
see small businesses doing the same
thing
now let's go to another sector so if you
are just a retail business right
on the retail side immediately you got
to get online
right very simple but you got to get
online and this can simply be through a
shopify site
uh or some other form of online
kind of storefront but you have to get
online you have to have a digital
presence you got to allow people to come
in and actually buy
this stuff sounds scary for small
business owners to try to set it up but
ultimately what ends up happening is
uh it's very simple to set up if you
know what you're doing right and what i
mean by that is
using shopify and stripe and all of
these services that now have
have been created you should be able to
actually set this up
um you know pretty simply if not there's
plenty of people in your local community
who can help you do that
who understand how to use these tools
pretty easily go online google around
you'll find somebody
the other piece to a retail business
again ip
what are the things that you do better
than everybody else that you can
productize in order to then go and you
can sell that online or you can sell it
in your store
so if you sell some sort of physical
good right are there other things that
you can go into
kind of concentrically expand into in
order to actually
um create more skus create more revenue
channels for yourself
is there a service type business that
you can add is there something that you
can do
where maybe people actually pay you for
your time right there's all of these
pieces that people need to start to
understand is
it's no longer the constrictions of just
your physical retail location
you have to start thinking about what
are the digital assets i owe right
intellectual property uh expertise all
of these things are monetizable
if you can figure out how to put them in
front of the right customers at the
right time
so that's a retail store now if you
start to get into things like
freelancers etc
right um you know take personal trainers
freelancers basically anybody who
um has a a a business in which
uh they don't work at a company it's
just them as an individual
right and and so these people are
actually the people who uh
this is like the super bowl right if you
know what you're doing or you can get up
to speed quickly
you should be absolutely crushing it
right now what i mean by that is
you've yes you have been given a
obstacle that you can't physically go in
person so
if you do consulting you can't
physically go in person if you do
personal training you can't physically
go in person
but what you now are forced to do is
think how do i do this in a digital
first
manner and what i mean by that is let's
say that you're a personal trainer and
you used to train one-on-one
or you would train two people uh you
know at max or three people in a group
well now all of a sudden you can
actually get on zoom and you can train
50 people at one time
so you so it's not the same experience
but what you can actually do is you can
overcome that by simply going after way
more volume
right and doing an in-home workout but
what you've got to be good at is you got
to be able to get distribution and so
what we're seeing is every single small
business owner in america
is now being forced to figure out how to
use the internet
to create distribution for the products
and services that they have right
so we're literally getting a an
acceleration of
the training that small business owners
have
what i believe is going to happen while
there is a ton of short-term pain and
while i believe that 20
of small businesses are not going to
make it out of this uh and about 10
of um jobs in america when this is all
nets out uh are going to be lost because
of this
i believe that this will be a net
positive over a very long period of time
and that is because what we are
essentially forcing small business
owners to do is be retrained right now
right they historically have had one
single skill set those who have thrived
in the past have figured out the online
world but majority of or many of the
small business owners have not
and now what we're doing is we're
basically forcing all small business
owners in america to
upgrade their skills to upskill
themselves to learn how to thrive in a
digital first world
and so over a long period of time
that'll be a net positive uh before i
forget i'm going to
answer a ton of questions so go ahead
and drop all of your questions in here
i'm going to do my absolute best to get
to every single one of them
uh also housekeeping things please hit
the thumbs up button right underneath
the video
smash that button make sure you're
subscribed to the channel and then i
write a daily letter every single day to
50 000
investors about business technology and
finance go subscribe at pompletter.com
there's a link in the description i'll
drop it in the chat right now but
make sure that you're subscribed to that
it's uh probably the place where i put
my all of my thoughts every single
morning about a bunch of this stuff so
if you
uh find this stuff interesting then go
ahead and subscribe there and
you can get that in your inbox every
single day so uh another piece that i
want to talk about
is uh on the regulatory front what we
are going to start seeing is i believe
we're going to start seeing small
business owners say
why am i paying for the physical retail
location and
i need to just go digitally only right
so take that whole foods if i can go
digital only right not allow customers
to walk in
can i actually expand my margins can i
improve my business right
same thing i think is going to happen
with a lot of different businesses where
they say maybe i don't need to pay for
that prime retail location
on madison avenue instead can i put
something in long island city which is
more of a warehouse do online ordering
and then just deliver the things
directly to people's doors right so
people are going to start to change the
operational
structure that they have in order to
improve the
prospects of their business now what
that ends up doing is that ends up
creating a chain reaction that chain
reaction ends up being something around
commercial real estate right and so that
commercial real estate we are going to
see the reimagining of the uses of this
commercial real estate so
all that retail space it's not going to
be used for retail space for
a long time it may come back at some
point but for the
foreseeable future i believe that those
um
kind of commercial real estate buildings
that that floor that ground level that
retail space
is going to be hap is going to have to
be used for something else and so what i
think you're going to start to see is
you're going to start to see
companies moving into that space i
wouldn't be surprised they turn into
event spaces and
all kinds of different things right
maybe even kind of food and beverage
whatever they can do to get that space
filled but it's not going to be used for
the same things that it previously was
and so
it's going to be really really
interesting to kind of watch that
evolution
now who are the beneficiaries of all of
this well think through
all the infrastructure that is needed in
order to kind of facilitate this
accelerated trend from an analog world
to a digital world
so amazon is going to do amazing aws
everyone's going to use it right
amazon logistics and storage going to do
amazing
right uh any sort of delivery right
amazon is going to do amazing
then if you go and you look at things
like ubereats seamless grubhub
right doordash all the way through
they're going to continue to do really
well the the consumer behavior has
shifted
to a more kind of food delivery model
online ordering model and so those
businesses will continue to do well
places like shopify right shopify's
whole motto of arm the rebels allow
these small business owners to set up
online storefronts
and get going very quickly those
businesses are going to do amazing
because what they're basically doing is
it's almost like taking a tax on the
trend right so as this trend accelerates
every single time somebody converts one
of those companies is going to get paid
right google
uh will do the same thing facebook and
google will continue to take ad revenue
right you want to drive traffic to your
online store well you got to spend money
on advertising and so those companies
will continue to take
kind of their tax and so what you're
seeing is uh kind of these large
technology companies
actually have figured out how to provide
infrastructure that is going to be the
foundation for this trend and so if
you're an investor
you start thinking about okay well if
this trend accelerates and continues
doing what it's doing which i personally
believe it will
then there are certain companies that
are going to drastically benefit from
that moving forward in the future and
the question just becomes how fast does
that happen
uh and how quickly will small business
owners actually retrain themselves and
get online right that's the big
uh question that nobody really knows yet
so i'm gonna stop there
uh i have no clue how long that what
what oh i guess i went for like 25
minutes
um let's see what questions you guys
have drop all your questions in here and
i'm going to get through as many of
these as i can
uh yes crypto uh i don't care about the
day-to-day price swings
uh it is down over the last couple of
days but again
you know uh bitcoin for example is the
best performing asset class
uh since the beginning of this year i
was up about
i think it's up like 60 percent uh this
year gold's up like 20 25
stocks are basically flat uh to a little
up kind of single digit positives
and so i think that we'll continue to
see uh krypto do really well you got the
macro
uh environment kind of the tailwind but
you also then have
um the uh just kind of economics 101
supply and demand right you've got a
fixed cap
supply asset as demand increases you'll
get a price increase
in us dollar value so i think that's
going to continue to happen
uh what other questions um do i think
movie theaters will be amazon hubs all
right so this is a great uh question
talk about reimagining spaces right one
of the things that
i've talked before about is of the use
of malls so if you think of a mall
kind of in the uh historic sense in like
a suburban area
right it's very big in terms of actual
square footage it's got a lot of open
area it's also got the parking lot
it's usually got some land with it etc
it would not surprise me if we start to
see people going and buying up these uh
pieces of real estate
and then reusing them for something else
so one example that i've used in the
past is
uh usually at the ends of uh the mall or
the department stores
what you could do is you could actually
take those department stores you could
turn them into apartments
kind of college dorm style you could
solicit people to move there if they're
like remote workers
into a really cool environment then you
basically take all of the
real estate in between the ends of the
department stores and you turn that into
a mini city right and you basically
recreate the urban environment but you
do it
in kind of a suburban area so the cost
is cheaper
you can do all kinds of cool things with
the parking lot right that kind of
surrounds you turn into parks walkways
all that kind of stuff
and so don't be surprised if there's
tons of development projects where
people go in and they buy
up this old um or kind of
cheap real estate and they try to do
interesting things with it
also i'm waiting to see what happens
with college campuses right
obviously i think a lot of people
understand now that there's this huge uh
higher education bubble
if there are uh i don't think like the
harvards and yales are going anywhere
but
if you kind of look at the lower tier uh
colleges
they usually own a lot of land they've
got really big buildings um if they
become
uh if they come under pressure from
people not wanting to pay you know 30 40
50 000
a year to do zoom classes and people are
uncomfortable actually going to
the physical location some of that real
estate will become distressed and
somebody will swoop in and then kind of
what happens there
how do people reimagine that uh another
thing is
uh somebody mentioned um movie theaters
right there's all kinds of these large
uh buildings i don't think that movie
theaters necessarily go away
i do think that you'll see a different
experience right so
um in in terms of maybe what they end up
doing is they say look we actually don't
want to pack these
uh with as many people and so we're
going to kind of create
auxiliary services in order to establish
more margin but we'll put less people in
there so
something like you know the dinner and
movie type uh environment you can see
that happening
um and then there's going to be
something that just go out of business
right when they go out of business it's
a big physical location and so
i don't know necessarily if movie
theaters are the best place to create
like amazon warehouses
um but you could see them being used as
kind of this hub and spoke model
uh for various types of businesses and
so i think that
people just need to start kind of
reimagining what is the real estate that
is around me
and how will that evolve over time but i
think that's a really really great
uh point there uh why is the stimulus
funds package for the small business
have so many pitfalls and
tie-ins yeah look obviously the things
these things are incredibly
uh complex they were done very quickly
too remember back in march i mean this
was put together in a matter of weeks
um we saw things like the airlines where
you know they took the bailout money and
they were told you can't lower anyone's
um salary right or the uh hourly rate
uh and so they said okay no problem but
then all they did was they just cut
hours they said instead of working 40
hours you can only work 30. so in
essence they were paying their people
less
but they abided by the letter of the law
and so they basically found a loophole
right i think that that's happening
they've got lots of lawyers right and
and kind of um those large corporations
are going to always be incentivized to
do that
on the small business side um you know
there's a lot of small businesses that
they basically started to take the pbp
loans and didn't fully even understand
what exactly uh were some of the rules
around it right if you remember i mean
the first chance was gone like almost
immediately
so i think that there was just a lot of
fear there was a lot of
necessity uh there's a lot of kind of
short-term cash crunch
uh and now as kind of the dust is
settling a little bit uh people are
starting to understand what are some of
those
um you know requirements uh some of them
are you know okay and some of them i
think people are saying yeah
i wish it wasn't like that um but you
know at the end of the day
uh there's kind of always hindsight bias
of like
i wish they had done this or i wish i
had done that but you have to remember
this was put together in a matter of
weeks
um you know back in march and ultimately
they were able to get money in the hands
of uh business owners
uh and and i have no doubt that they
saved businesses the question is just
should they have saved the businesses or
should they have allowed the free market
to rain i think you guys know where i
stand on that
um okay election uh i don't think it
matters
and what i mean by that is uh i think
that
at this point uh there is a very high
degree of distrust with the government
um i mean if you look at the local and
state level
uh literally people are like oh my god
we have such incompetent people
uh running the governments that actually
have probably a more
direct impact on me you know pretty much
across the country
the way that mayors and governors have
uh
you know handled this entire situation
is pretty pathetic frankly
there was a very real lack of leadership
and then those that were pounding their
chest you know
claiming to be leaders they actually are
the ones who made the worst decisions
right if you look at andrew cuomo in new
york for example
you know he's been pounding his chest
saying he's a real leader he literally
wrote a book
right to give you guys a sense of this
one we've got a governor who uh was
pounding his chest saying that he was a
leader the entire time he wrote a book
during the pandemic that book was
released and on top of all of that he is
responsible for
a very high number of people uh dying in
new york
uh because he implemented a program that
took covid patients and put them back
into nursing homes
and so when you just look at it it says
you know does the election matter in
terms of who is the president
of course right the election determines
who the president is but i do not think
that people
uh will fare well if they just sit back
and they say hey i'm going to rely on
the government to help me right i
actually think that it's the exact
opposite
you have to take personal responsibility
you have to understand that no one is
going to look out for you like you will
look out for yourself
um and so it doesn't matter who the
president is right it doesn't matter who
your governor it doesn't matter who your
mayor is
you you have to figure out how to be
successful
uh whether you're running a small
business whether you're just an employee
right if you're starting
uh something else you have to figure out
how to be uh successful
now when i say all of that do i think
that there are certain candidates that
are more pro-business than others of
course do i think some are
uh more um kind of you know heavy on the
taxation side versus not
of course i think that people kind of
generally understand where democrats and
republicans fall on this
i personally think that um both are
flawed strategies right we've seen that
i mean right now we've got politicians
that are literally arguing over or
they're not even at the negotiation
table anymore but they're arguing over
trillions of dollars
so one party says hey we should print
you know a trillion plus the other party
says we should print three plus trillion
dollars
so it kind of is just like you're
throwing you know caution to the wind
and saying look
you know at this point what's the
difference right they both are
um kind of addicted to monetary stimulus
they're both addicted to
a very unique uh perspective on the
world i personally don't agree with that
view of the world and so i think that
you just have to as an individual or as
a small business
understand that you have to look out for
yourself you have to put yourself
in a position to be successful uh if
you're a restaurateur in new york city
of course the mayor's
decision to not allow you to do indoor
dining until there's a vaccine which is
absurd
of course that is going to make your job
harder it puts an obstacle in your way
but rather than sit around and complain
and and be upset
at the mayor you just have to understand
an entrepreneur's job is to learn what
the rules are
tell me the rules okay cool i can't have
indoor dining okay what are my other
rules okay i can have outdoor dyna i can
have this i can have that i can't have
this
got it once you understand what those
rules are then you gotta go win the game
and i think that's the part where the
true entrepreneurs shine
uh and kind of the people who like the
idea of being an entrepreneur but they
get put in these wartime situations
they actually struggle and so i think
that's a key piece is you know
i really don't care who the president is
and why do i not care who the president
is because i don't think that that
determines whether a business is
successful or not i think that
ultimately it's the entrepreneur who
decides that and people need to take the
personal responsibility
to be successful regardless of the
environment so i'll stop there on the on
the politics stuff but that's my general
um
sense uh let's see here what other
questions do you guys have
uh in the next six months housing will
bust no one can pay eight months back
run or even the back rent now people
can't pay this month
uh from brian kitching yeah so look
obviously there's a ton of pressure on
the on the rents and mortgage side
um what we are actually seeing is a
explosion
in residential home purchases right in
uh and really it's just because there's
cheap capital flooding the market
uh and so anytime you can refi or you
can get cheap capital of course people
are incentivized
to go buy new homes and do things like
that uh at the same time we're obviously
seeing a freeze on eviction so it's kind
of hard to understand how much pressure
there is
we know that there's a very high
percentage of people who are not paying
their rents or paying their mortgages
uh and so ultimately like this you you
can't just kick the can down the road
forever
right because either landlords are going
to require the back paid of rent
or they're going to default and so what
you end up getting is you end up getting
this like chain reaction
um and it's just a really really bad
situation and so
uh ultimately what we are going to see
is we are going to see a lot of stress
in the market the question is just when
does it happen right if they continue to
pump monetary stimulus into the uh into
the economy
they could keep this going for the next
year plus right i mean
there's no there's no reason why it's
going to end next month or six months
from now
uh you know it's kind of like how long
do they want to play this game
but ultimately kind of you got to pay
for your sins right and what i mean by
that is
if you haven't paid rent since march and
you're a business
at some point your landlord is going to
make you pay rent and they maybe they
don't make you pay the whole thing but
they're gonna make it pay something
uh because they've got bills to pay and
so i think that people just have to
understand that like
we still are only five or six months
into this like this is likely to be a
multi-year
impact uh on the u.s economy and so we
cannot think that we are out of the
woods yet right obviously the stock
market drew down
uh over the last couple of days uh
there's a lot of people who would argue
oh there's no more monetary stimulus
coming like the market was expecting
just to continue to pump until
you know the uh election day but if no
more uh injection of capital comes into
the market like where is the next buyer
going to come from where's the
additional capital going to come from
i don't think people yet no my guess is
that we will get more monetary stimulus
that we will see
kind of a stock market continue to
explode in through november
who knows though i don't play the public
markets but that's just my general
opinion
um so let's see what happens here
[Music]
what other questions what other
questions uh why should real estate
crash when there will be more inflation
i don't see why it crashes
so this is a great point uh basically if
uh
you know you're pumping so much money
into the economy and there's three plus
trillion dollars and printed there's
probably more on the way
uh all you're doing is you're devaluing
the dollar right and as you devalue the
dollar people are going to seek
inflation hedge assets they're going to
seek real estate precious metals bitcoin
in some weird world stocks are serving
as an inflation hedge right now right
and so what they end up doing is they
convert their dollars into assets and
they hold those assets and the dollar de
values
and so those asset prices go up right
literally quantitative easing
my friend travis cling always says it's
ubi for rich people right
i think the same thing um is a great
argument the problem is
uh a price appreciation of real estate
doesn't make up for the short-term cash
flow crunch
meaning that just because your real
estate is going up in value
you don't have that cash and so you've
got to pay you've got bills to pay
and so what ultimately will occur is
just how long can somebody remain
solvent on a property right so if i
let's say i bought a property for
a hundred dollars and it's going up in
value it goes up to 120
that sounds that's great i made 20 this
year because my uh real estate
appreciated in price
but the problem is that i've got to pay
my dollar a month mortgage right or my
ten dollar
uh mortgage every single year and if i
don't have cash flow where do i get that
ten dollars from
so either i have some other source of
income or cash right
i've got a balance sheet or i've got uh
cash flow coming from somewhere else and
i can use that to pay off that that
mortgage payment
uh but if i don't then i'm actually
forced to liquidate the property in
order to cover the mortgage and so in
that situation
i probably am not going to be able to
sell for 120 because there's no buyer
and if there's no buyer then what i'm
going to do is i'm going to start to
draw down that price point
right and so maybe somebody will buy it
at uh 105
rather than 120. and so you'll start to
see kind of this distressed sellers
uh if we go for long enough where
they're not getting the cash flow to
actually cover the mortgages and so
that's kind of how i think about the the
real estate prices and uh how they could
um actually fall uh same thing with
homes obviously right is if you lose
your job or you don't have it the same
income you can't afford the mortgage
then you you're forced to sell uh
thankfully there's cheap capital in the
market so people are refinancing and
doing things like that
but i do think that that is um you know
the general way to uh
to think about it uh d5
all right we'll talk about d5 real quick
uh i am long-term
bullish on the idea of decentralized
financial applications
bitcoin was the first one 200 plus
billion dollar asset now
uh there will be many more right whether
it's through lending or other types of
um you know kind of mechanisms what i am
short term
bearish on is the current iteration of
the d5 applications
all i continue to see is two things i
continue to see technology not products
meaning that people are building all
these cool technologies and like look at
how cool it is
but it's not a product that an everyday
user can use and so you
who nobody cares about your technology
they want to use a product right
i can't tell you how my apple computer
works but it's an awesome product
right same thing with my cell phone same
thing when i go and i actually use the
internet right and i go through a
browser i can't tell you how any of it
works
i don't care how it works i use an
awesome product
and so people want products not
technology and i think that's one of the
key missing pieces to the current
iteration of these d5
projects is that they're all about the
technology they're not actually building
products that people can use
the second thing is that it's a lot of
just financial engineering there's no
difference between the financial
engineering that goes on on wall street
and a lot of the financial engineering
that's going on
in these d5 projects and so what you end
up seeing is something to the effect of
people literally launching projects and
what they're saying is here is how i'm
going to financially engineer a return
right through all kinds of mechanisms
and again that doesn't mean that it's
good or bad
it's just i don't want to play games
where it's dependent on
value increases or dependent on
financial engineering
right what i want to see is true value
creation right not financial engineering
that leads to value capture
and so i think that's kind of my two big
um you know bearish points
on the current iteration of d5 is
technology not products and there's a
lot of financial engineering not actual
value
creation now over time i expect that to
change right if you go back to the
internet go through all these different
iterations
with technology it always starts out
with technology before you get the
products so that's kind of a natural
progression
and the other thing is when there's
finance involved there's always a lot of
financial
manipulation financial engineering and
then eventually you get to the true
value creation
and so i think that's what um we're
going to end up seeing there
but but that's generally my my idea um
people asking about international flows
of capital for real estate
uh take new york city for example uh in
the mid 2010s there was an immense
amount of capital flowing in from asia
china specifically
uh and so builders saw that they got
their eyes wide you know they started
salivating over oh my god i can build
all these buildings and all these
foreign investors are gonna buy up
uh and so they started building the
problem is it takes you know 24
plus months to uh to build a building
and so by the time they actually
completed the buildings
uh and they had the inventory ready to
sell uh there's new capital controls in
asia a lot of foreign investors had
disappeared
capital came down in terms of how much
was coming into uh the market and so now
all of a sudden we have an all-time high
of
unused inventory in new york city uh and
so of course that's going to lead to
lower prices right there's just so much
inventory on the market
uh a lot of that is new builds and then
also people leaving new york because of
the pandemic
so it's kind of this perfect storm where
you just get a ton of
un um unused or you know unspoken for
inventory on the market
and that's obviously going to have the
material impact on price so
that's what uh i would talk about there
let's see
when will prices go up on goods what's
your time frame guess thanks again
uh manuel so uh goods are already going
up
like here here's the big lies if you
look at the official cpi numbers
uh it always is like oh there's no
inflation or very low inflation
but if you go look at um kind of the the
people who say look here's the
unofficial numbers
i saw one thing and i'll have to uh i'll
have to remember what the website is and
and i'll put it in the comments when
when i find it but basically it was
measuring like you know
what over the last 12 months has been
the price appreciation of various goods
and what you see is like sometimes
already double digit percentages
and so there's no secret here that
prices are going up prices are
absolutely going up because of inflation
it's just a matter
of does it make it into the official cpi
numbers or not and remember
right one of my big things and i think
it's really important for people to
understand
is that they have to realize that
everyone does not experience the same
level of inflation
what that means is that um yes you can
get
uh let's say a two percent cpi number
but that two percent
is only experienced by the absolute top
you know 10 or 20
of americans right the riches of the
rich they have two percent
and it's because majority of their
wealth is actually in real assets and
therefore they're benefiting from the
inflation
but the people at the bottom l uh kind
of rung of the socio-economic ladder
they're experiencing at two percent uh
cpi numbers they're probably
experiencing somewhere between
six eight or ten percent right uh in
terms of inflation it's because
they uh live paycheck to paycheck they
keep all their wealth and cash
uh and the goods that they consume are
more likely to be inflationary
versus other people and so it's just
this environment where
the mainstream media the legacy media
continues to talk about official numbers
but what they
fail to do is they fail to unpack the
fact that
that official number is not what the
bottom 40 percent of americans
experience
bottom 40 of americans coming out of the
2008 2009 crisis
they probably experienced somewhere
closer to 10 inflation rather than 2
percent
right but again that goes against the
narrative of the official numbers and so
those official cpi numbers
imagine thinking that a billionaire and
somebody on unemployment insurance both
have
cons one consume the same goods and two
have the same level of inflation
it's insane that's not how the world
works and so i think that uh
it's really hard for legacy
organizations to uh
end up creating some level of uh nuance
in their coverage but that's ultimately
what we need in order for people to
understand what's going on here
um so it's uh it's pretty sad but hey
that's what it is
that's what um what's going on uh how
much does inflation matter if computer
tech gets better and cheaper
uh this great question so technology
inherently is deflationary uh so it
should drive down
cost uh and you see this with you know
everything from uh kind of technology
products
uh all the way to um you know kind of
the implementation in uh
supply chains manufacturing facilities
etc so
the more that we become tech first or
digitally native
uh as a country and as an economy and as
a business uh what you will see is you
will see that deflationary
impact now the question is and this is
like the trillion dollar question right
now
is all the quantitative easing is it
going to get soaked up by those
deflationary forces or will there be
very high levels of inflation
i personally think that you're not going
to be able to print three plus trillion
dollars and not see some level of
inflation
there's good um kind of data to suggest
already that we're starting to see
higher levels of inflation but but
that's happening on a specific
good standpoint not so much in kind of
the macro
environment uh and the official numbers
obviously uh you know
they'll kind of manipulate those as much
as they can to kind of continue to hide
the fact that when you print money all
you are doing is you are
asking the people with the least amount
of money in your economy to pay for
that growth right so you can basically
do three things you can allow a free
market to rain
that free market will go through boom
and bust cycles they will be really
really good times and there will be bad
times
but that free market ultimately will
help to find kind of equilibrium
um and efficiencies in the market the
second thing that you can do
is you can do what the government has
done for the last six fiscal years you
can
increase taxes and so as they've done
this on the tax side
every single year for the last six years
the government has hit a record high
in terms of federal income tax revenue
meaning that they are taking
more money right actually getting more
revenue from
uh citizens of the united states yet
every single year we're seeing a wider
and wider
intra-year deficit meaning that in the
year 2016 or 15 or 17
the amount of money in the deficit right
that the difference between what we
spent what we actually brought in
increases it's getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger which adds
more and more uh to the national debt
and so it
is not a revenue problem we've every
single year for the last six years
brought in
record levels of revenue it is a
spending problem
right it's very obvious if i said to you
hey every single year you keep getting
paid more money than you've ever been
paid before
yet every single year somehow you end up
going deeper and deeper in debt
you would say to me now i need to make
more money what you would say is i need
to stop spending
and so that's what's going on at the
government level the numbers are it's so
obvious what's happening anyone who is
running a business would look at that
and say
obviously it's a spending problem it's
not a revenue problem because we
continue to take in record revenue every
single year
yet even though we're taking in record
revenue so we took in more revenue last
year than the year before
but we still spent even more how does
that happen of course it's a spending
problem
that is the problem when you live in a
inflationary debt fueled
economy because the politicians don't
have to answer to anybody because what
they're doing is they're taking the
money
right or they're taking the value from
the bottom 40 of americans and they're
using that to pay for it
and so at that time not only are you
taking in tax money but you're also
devaluing the dollar
and you're hurting the bottom 40 that's
where you get a widening
uh wealth inequality gap that wealth
inequality gap is only going to
accelerate
remember during the pandemic the
billionaires in the united states have
made almost 800
trillion or 800 billion dollars the
billionaires in the united states
during the pandemic have made almost 800
billion dollars while
almost 60 million americans have lost
their jobs now
that's not the billionaire's fault all
they've been doing is running their
business
right but what it is is the government
gave that 800 billion dollars
to those rich people again quantitative
easing
is universal basic income for rich
people and so when you pump a bunch of
money into the economy it drove asset
prices up who owns those assets the rich
people
and of course if the government's going
to do that you're going to make the rich
richer and the poor poor that's what
we're watching play out
so again you have to get out of this
world
the problem is that we are addicted we
are absolutely addicted to a
quantitative easing world and so the
problem becomes
that we can't break the addiction
because it will be so painful
but if we are smart and we actually go
ahead and do it
and we just say you know what the next
two years are going to suck it's going
to be
horrific but after two years we're going
to set the floor and we're going to be
in a great position
to then have this great prosperous time
i actually think that's the best thing
that we can do and so if you go back and
look at like what paul volcker did
paul volcker actually said hey i'm going
to do the hard things
i'm going to do the things that everyone
doesn't want me to do and it's going to
cause
really bad economic pain in the short
term but it's going to create this great
environment for us to have a very long
prosperous
economic environment and so he actually
oversaw people forget this paul volcker
who was
the federal federal reserve chairman at
one point he oversaw
two uh recessions two recessions
he intentionally took steps to raise
interest rates and create an environment
that created
two separate recessions that he oversaw
but that laid the foundation for the run
from
in the 80s and into the 90s this great
economic boom
and so again that's the point that we're
at now is we're going to have to make
hard decisions
i don't know who's going to be the
people that are willing to do it but
somebody's going to have to be willing
to do it
because that is what is going to get us
back into a position where we can have
true economic growth remember go back to
1971
if you denominate the stock market in
dollars it's a perfect line up
45 degree angle why it's not because the
stocks are going up in value
it's because the dollar is being
devalued how do i know if you take those
same stocks and you devout and you uh
denominate them
in gold the stock market is down since
1971.
so by changing the currency you
understand that the stock market is not
actually gaining
value it's the dollar being devalued
and so in that world you have to start
asking yourself
how do we get back to true growth not
inflation
adjusted growth right or not uh
inflation fueled growth but actual true
growth
and that is going to be a very very kind
of short-term painful experience but we
have to get back on that track i think
that's the only way that you solve a lot
of these problems
uh can we i'm gonna answer three more
questions before i forget
smash that like button go ahead and make
sure you're subscribed to the channel
and then i write a daily letter uh
pompletter.com
uh to 50 000 investors every single day
i talk about business technology and
finance make sure you go and subscribe
to that
i think people will really enjoy it so
pompletter.com
uh can we incentivize the wealthy to
invest in small businesses for higher
returns through some sort of government
regulation
uh kevin schwartz uh i absolutely do not
think that we should use government
uh regulation to tell investors what to
invest in
uh i think we need less government
regulation not more
um you know historically what we have
done this whole idea of like tax the
rich this is one of my favorite things
tax the rich right as an example not
what kevin is talking about
but a different example uh why would we
tax the rich more money we're literally
asking the best capital allocators in
the world
to take their money and give it to the
worst capital allocators in the world
the government
that makes no sense right that makes
literally no sense
people who have created enormous amounts
of wealth they're wealth creators right
they're value creators
we're now asking them to turn over their
resources to
value destructors right the government
does not create value the government
destroys value
and so what ultimately occurs is from a
resource standpoint we should do
everything we possibly can to
incentivize that
uh transfer of capital and resources
from those who have a lot
to even more people like them right so i
think to kevin's question
is there a way where we can get people
who are incredibly wealthy
create tax advantaged programs say hey
listen if you invest in small businesses
if you invest in more entrepreneurship
if you invest in innovation if you
invest in
uh kind of things where we are going to
give your resources
to other highly capable intelligent
value creators
there will be tax benefits to that i i
think that's the type of stuff that ends
up becoming
really really interesting so you're not
using government regulation necessarily
to force them to do it
instead what you're doing is you're
using incentives to help transfer that
resources
don't give the resources to the
government the government's horrible at
allocating resources
they destroy immense value every single
year
they literally just light money on fire
right instead take those resources
and share them with other value creators
give them to other
people who want to build companies who
want to drive innovation that's how you
solve problems
you give resources to problem solvers
you don't give it to bureaucrats
i think that's the type of thing where
um if we had a an administration that
walked in and said look here's the deal
the government can't solve your problems
and we're not going to try instead what
we're going to do is we're basically
going to facilitate
every single problem solver innovator
and entrepreneur in the united states
we're going to help you get as many
resources as possible and we're going to
get the hell out of your way
i think there's a lot of people who
would go for that because ultimately
what you end up seeing is you end up
seeing a world where
we want to solve problems we want to
create value when we want to drive
innovation
we don't want to sit in a world where
literally we've got fat cat bureaucrats
who say don't do as i uh say do is or
don't do as i do do as i say
and what they ultimately end up doing is
they end up destroying tons and tons of
value
right so that that's kind of how i think
that uh we should solve a lot of these
problems is simply just
incentivize the resources to flow to
entrepreneurs and problem solvers not to
flow to the bureaucrats in the
government but we'll see how that goes
uh all right i'm gonna take two more
questions and then uh i am going to be
out of here
uh bitcoin and smp highly correlated uh
from
rajaj i think is how you pronounce your
name uh look the in short periods of
time
uh especially during the liquidity
crisis like we saw uh
march april and into may uh of course
every assets correlation goes towards
one
right dollar strengthening asset prices
are dropping um what you end up seeing
though is over very long periods of time
five six seven eight years
bitcoin has a very low correlation to
other assets i think that
um the correlation uh going into
february was like .15
which is very very low um and at times
of global instability actually it uh
it's even had negative correlations so
like
you know may 2019 if i remember the
numbers correctly it was like
negative 0.9 uh to stocks and negative
0.8 to gold or something like that right
and so what you know you can pick any
point in time and see high levels of
correlation
uh and when you have massive
manipulation of markets right where
there's so much quantitative easing
um being kind of thrown at problems uh
asset correlations are going to
trend towards one what you want to see
though is
kind of over longer time periods so five
plus years you still have a very low
correlation so i don't worry about kind
of the short term stuff i just look at
the longer term
standpoint um all right i'll end with
this i see a lot of questions about
uh precious metals so uh on the precious
metal side gold silver etc
i personally think that any inflation
hedge asset is going to do well
uh moving forward and that's because
even if high levels of inflation never
occur
i believe that they will but even if
they don't occur the fear of the
inflation is more important than the
inflation itself and what i mean by that
is if people think inflation is coming
the capital flows into inflation hedge
assets right so if you go back and you
look at
2008 over the summer gold draws down 30
percent
government steps in they print a bunch
of money people are worried about
inflation everyone
moves their assets into inflation hedge
asses gold then goes up 200
hits an all-time high in 2011. same
thing's happening right now people are
all talking about inflation whether it
happens or not doesn't matter
capital is starting to flow into
inflation hedge assets and therefore
you'll see those asset prices go up
if you look at gold or bitcoin compared
to let's say stocks gold and bitcoin
have done much better this year than
uh the stock market now with that said
uh ultimately when you look at the
inflation hedge bucket you've got real
estate you've got precious metals you've
got bitcoin and again as i mentioned
even stocks at some point
um are not becoming an inflation hedge
asset in some weird way
all of that is great and all of those
assets are likely to do well
i personally believe bitcoin will be the
out performer right paul tudor jones
wrote a piece
called it the great monetary inflation
uh he said look i want to be with the
fastest horse i think bitcoin is the
fastest horse
there's two ways to look at this one is
bitcoin is a much more global asset
it's more accessible than than any other
assets right so if you want to buy gold
or you want to buy bitcoin which one's
easier to buy
bitcoin globally for sure um and so
that's where you see a lot of people
going in
and doing that the second thing is from
a market structure standpoint so
uh bitcoin is a very small market cap
it's only 200 billion dollar market cap
and therefore it takes less dollars to
move it more on a percentage basis right
so if you go let's say for example you
put a billion dollars into
uh bitcoin or you put a billion dollars
into gold bitcoin's going to move more
simply because it's a smaller market cap
and it's got more volatility to it
so volatility works in both directions
can work against you
or it's a bad thing when it goes against
you right so if you're long bitcoin and
bitcoin goes down
uh you say hey it's volatile that's a
bad thing but if you're long bitcoin and
bitcoin goes up a lot that's also
volatility
but now you like that volatility because
it's going uh
in your direction so i believe that uh
it's a highly volatile asset i think the
macro environment plus the structure of
bitcoin in terms of the supply demand
uh kind of relationship is going to
drive a much higher bitcoin price moving
forward
uh and so for those that are long
obviously that volatility will work
uh for them if you're short it and it
goes up then obviously that works
against you and so that's kind of how i
think
about precious metals i think they'll do
well but i just think that bitcoin will
do much better
given the volatility given the small
market cap than given the macro
environment
along with the global accessibility so
that's it for today uh remember please
hit that like button so more people will
see this on the internet
uh we can get more people educated uh
make sure you're subscribed to the
channel and then i just put uh in the
description
in the pinned comment and then also in
the chat
go subscribe to pompletter.com write a
letter to 50
000 investors every single day all about
business technology and finance if you
liked any of the content here or learned
anything today
i think that you will really enjoy that
so go to pompletter.com
and i will talk to you guys later in the
week